हेलो एवरीवन एंड
फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो
आई होप सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही होगी और सबको
लाइव स्ट्रीमिंग दिखाई दे रही होगी। प्लीज
चैट में कंफर्म कर दीजिए। सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है और स्ट्रीमिंग दिखाई दे
रही है? प्लीज बता दीजिए।
यस या नो चैट में जल्दी बता दीजिए।
ओके थैंक यू। अच्छी बात है। फिर आप सबको
दिखाई सुन दिखाई दे रही है तो और सुनाई भी
दे रही है तो आवाज मेरी लाउड एंड क्लियर
है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सबको लाउड एंड क्लियर है मेरी आवाज?
तो मुझे सबसे पहले एक चीज बताइए।
प्रीवियस क्लास में जो भी कुछ मैंने आपको
बताया था वीबीए के बारे में फंडामेंटल्स
या डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट के बारे में सबको सब
कुछ क्लियर है?
सबको सब कुछ क्लियर है?
सब कुछ क्लियर है? सबको सब कुछ समझ में आ
गया था?
अगर सबको सब कुछ समझ में आ गया था तो फिर
आज हम अपनी क्लास में स्टार्ट करने जा रहे
हैं मैक वीबीए मै डेवलपमेंट के बारे में।
ओके? तो आई होप सबको पता चल गया होगा कि
आज से हमारी क्लासेस किस चीज के बारे में
रहने वाली हैं। हमारी मैक्सिमम क्लासेस
प्रैक्टिकल्स रहेंगी और प्रैक्टिकल्स मैं
बिल्कुल ऐसे समझाऊंगा बिल्कुल जीरो से कि
मैं यह मान के चल रहा हूं कि आपको बिल्कुल
कोई भी नॉलेज नहीं है मैक डेवलपमेंट की
वीबीए मै डेवलपमेंट की। तो मैं यही सोचकर
आपको समझाने वाला हूं कि बिल्कुल जीरो
नॉलेज के साथ आपको स्टेप बाय स्टेप मैं
पहले आपके फंडामेंटल्स मतलब कि जो आपकी
बेसिक बिल्डिंग्स है इसमें वीबीए के अंदर
जो आपके लिए रिक्वायरमेंट है पेलोड लिखने
के लिए बेसिकली जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का वी
मैक में जो पेलोड लिखना है आपको अपना जो
टास्क परफॉर्म करवाना है क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक परफॉर्म करने के लिए या आपको रिवर्स
सेल लेना है या किसी कोई पेलोड ड्रॉप करना
है या पावर सेल का कमांड एग्जीक्यूट करना
है विद द हेल्प ऑफ एसॉफ्ट वर्ड या
Microsoft Excel तो उस चीज के बारे में
आपको बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग से मैं आपको
समझाऊंगा और जितनी भी चीजें यहां पर
डिस्कस की जाएंगी हर एक चीज आपके लिए
इंपॉर्टेंट है क्योंकि जो भी चीज मैं आपको
स्लाइड के थ्रू बताऊंगा या फिर मैं आपको
प्रैक्टिकल के थ्रू बताने वाला हूं। तो
प्लीज सारी चीजों को ध्यान से सुनना। जहां
पर नोट डाउन करने की जरूरत है उसको नोट
डाउन कर लेना। क्योंकि जो चीज मैं बताता
हूं कि यह आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन
है। यह चीज आपको ध्यान में रखनी है। तो
आपको ध्यान में रखनी है। ओके? आपको
बिल्कुल भी इस चीज को यह नहीं सोचना है कि
यह मेरे लिए यूज़लेस है। क्योंकि सारी
चीजें सोच समझकर आपको यहां पर बताई जाने
वाली है। हर एक चीज कैलकुलेटेड है। कहां
पर आपको क्या मिस्टेक नहीं करनी है वो भी
आपको यहां पर बताया जाएगा। तो आप उसको एक
इंपॉर्टेंट नोट समझकर, इंपॉर्टेंट
वार्निंग समझकर, हर एक चीज समझकर आप क्या
कर सकते हो? उसको यूज कर सकते हो। तो सबसे
पहले मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं कि
प्रैक्टिकल सेशंस कुछ ज्यादा होने वाले
हैं क्योंकि आपको आपका जो फंडामेंटल्स है,
आपकी जो चीजें हैं, वो क्लियर करने वाला
हूं। तो अराउंड फोर टू फाइव प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन तो होंगे ही होंगे किसके वीबीए के
ताकि आपके जो विजुअल जो मैक के जो पेलोड
बनाने के लिए जो आपका जो फंडामेंटल्स है
वो सब कुछ या जो भी आपकी रिक्वायरमेंट है
वो फुलफिल हो जाए ताकि आप एक खुद से नहीं
लिख पाओ तो एटलीस्ट आपको पता रहेगा कि
मुझे अगर एआई की हेल्प से भी लिखवाना है
तो मैं कैसे लिखवाऊंगा। स्मार्टली आप वो
प्लान कर पाओगे। ये चीज है। दूसरी चीज यह
है कि जो भी चीज मैं आपको यहां पर परफॉर्म
करके दिखाने वाला हूं वो सारा मेरे खुद के
लैपटॉप मेरे खुद के मशीन पर परफॉर्म करने
वाला हूं। तो मेरी एडवाइस आप लोगों के लिए
यह रहेगी प्लीज आप इसको बिना किसी परमिशन
के बिना किसी अनऑथराइज्ड वे में या बिना
किसी अथॉरिटी के आपके पास अगर अथॉरिटी ना
हो तो प्लीज इसको किसी के ऊपर भी परफॉर्म
मत करना। अह अपने खुद के लैपटॉप पर, खुद
की मशीन पर आप इसको परफॉर्म कर सकते हो।
खुद के आइसोलेटेड लैब्स पे परफॉर्म कर
सकते हो। बट किसी को बिना परमिशन के
टारगेट मत करना। क्योंकि यहां जो चीज़ें
सिखाई जा रही है वो आपको सिर्फ सिर्फ और
सिर्फ एजुकेशन पर्पस से आपको बताया जा रहा
है। कोई यहां पर कोई भी इंटेंशन नहीं है
कि आप उसका गलत यूज़ करो। ये चीज सबको समझ
में है। ये चीज क्लियर हो गई?
ओके? यह चीज सबको यह पॉइंट सबको ध्यान में
रहेगा।
क्या यह पॉइंट सबके ध्यान में रहेगा जो
मैं आपको बताने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं। ये
चीज अंडरस्टुड कि मैं आपको क्या बोल रहा
हूं। यह चीज आपको ध्यान में रखनी है। ओके?
आपके जो भी सवाल होंगे क्योंकि आज हम 5
मिनट से 7 मिनट तक लेट हो गए क्योंकि मेरी
तरफ से नेटवर्क इशू हो गया था। तो जिसकी
वजह से मैं अभी सीधा क्लास स्टार्ट कर रहा
हूं। और क्लास बिल्कुल छोटी-छोटी क्लासेस
करेंगे। अराउंड 45 टू 50 या वन हावर तक ही
क्लासेस करेंगे। क्योंकि बहुत सारी चीजें
हैं जो कुछ लोगों के लिए नई होंगी। आप लोग
जो पुराने हैं आपके लिए तो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं होगी। तो एक और चीज है प्लीज जब भी
मैं आपको कुछ भी पूछता हूं यस या नो? तो
आप लोगों से एक छोटी सी रिक्वेस्ट है। आप
इंटरेक्ट कीजिए। यस या नो का जवाब दे
दीजिए। या आपसे कोई भी सवाल पूछता हूं तो
भी आप उसका आंसर करने की कोशिश करना ताकि
आपका और मेरा इंटरेक्शन बना रहे वाया चैट।
बाकी आपके कोई भी सवाल होंगे उसको मैं
क्लास के एंड में ले लूंगा। तो चलिए फिर
हम स्टार्ट करते हैं अपने
स्टार्ट। तो सबसे पहले अगर आपको वीबीए मैक
डेवलपमेंट सीखना है। सबसे पहले आपको वीबीए
मैक डेवलपमेंट सीखना है तो उसके लिए आपकी
जो मशीन है जो आपकी जो विंडो मशीन है उसके
अंदर Microsoft Office इंस्टॉल होना
चाहिए। ठीक है? Microsoft ऑफिस में सब कुछ
आ जाता है। आपके MS Word, आपका MS Powpin,
आपका MS Exl
कुछ भी MS ऑफिस के अंदर पूरा पैकेज होता
है। तो आपके मशीन के ऊपर MS Office
इंस्टॉल होना चाहिए। अंडरस्टुड गाइस? जब
तक MS Office इंस्टॉल नहीं होगा तब तक आप
अपने प्रैक्टिकल सेशंस नहीं कर पाओगे। आप
अपने प्रैक्टिकल्स परफॉर्म नहीं कर पाओगे।
दूसरी चीज जब आपने एक बार MS Office
इंस्टॉल कर लिया तो मैं आपको स्टेप बता
रहा हूं। इन स्टेप को ध्यान से देखिए और
अगर साथ के साथ करने की कोशिश कर रहे हो
तो अच्छी बात है। अगर नहीं कर पा रहे हो
तो प्लीज मैं आप लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा कि नोट डाउन कर लीजिए कि कौन सा
स्टेप मैं कहां पर क्या परफॉर्म कर रहा
हूं। ओके कौन सा स्टेप कहां पर मैं
परफॉर्म कर रहा हूं। भाई देखो बात ऐसी है
Microsoft Office की बात हो रही है।
लाइब्रेर ऑफिस में मै काम नहीं करता। समझ
रहे हो? यहां पर माइक्रो Microsoft Office
की बात हो रही है तो Microsoft Office ही
चलेगा। ओके। तो चलिए फिर हम एक काम
करेंगे। जब आपने Microsoft Office ओपन
किया तो कुछ इस तरीके से आपको स्क्रीन ओपन
हो जाएगी। मैं आपको बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग से
दिखा देता हूं फिर कि इसको मैं मिनिमाइज
करता हूं और हमने क्या किया? सर्च करते
हैं हम। सबसे पहले हम सर्च करते हैं अपना
ऑफ W वर्ड। जैसे मैंने वर्ड ऑफ किया।
मैंने क्लिक किया। तो इस तरीके की आपको
स्क्रीन आपके सामने शो हो जाएगी। तो आपको
क्या करना है? उसके बाद आपको जाना है
किसके ऊपर?
ऑप्शंस के ऊपर। जब आप ऑप्शंस के ऊपर जाओगे
ऑप्शंस के ऊपर आपको कहां पर जाना है?
कस्टमाइज रिबन के ऊपर। ऑफिस के ऊपर आपको
कहां पर जाना है? जो कस्टमाइज रीजन है
यहां पर देखो दिख रहा है आपको? यहां पर
कस्टमाइज रीजन है 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 नाइंथ
नंबर पर तो यह जो कस्टमाइज रिबन है इसके
ऊपर क्लिक करना है आपको क्लिक करने के बाद
उसके बाद क्या करना है आपको यहां पर एक
टैब होगा यहां पर देख पा रहे होंगे यहां
पर एक टैब है कौन सा डेवलपर टैब ये रहा
ठीक है यहां पर आपको क्या करना है आपके
में क्या मिलेगा अनक्लिक मिलेगा आपके में
ऐसे अनक्लिक मिलने वाला है जैसे यह रहा
ऐसे अनक्लिक मिलेगा तो आपको क्या करना है
क्लिक करना है और ओके प्रेस करना है। मेरे
में मैक इनेबल है इसलिए डेवलपर टैब में
टिक मार्क है। तो आपको क्या करना है? इसको
क्या करना है? टिक करना है। अगर आपके में
टिक नहीं है तो टिक करना है। अगर पहले से
टिक है तो टिक करने की जरूरत नहीं है। तो
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है? ओके प्रेस कर
देना है। उसके बाद आपको ओके प्रेस कर देना
है। एक और काम करना था। बट एक काम कर देता
हूं मैं एक बार और फिर से उसके पास आ जाता
हूं। यह रहा। ठीक है? फिर से हम इधर ही आ
जाते हैं। आपको फिर से ऑप्शन पे जाना है।
आपने कस्टमाइज रिबन कर लिया। ये समझ में आ
गया स्टेप क्लियर आपको कि आपको
मैक इनेबल करने के लिए सबसे पहले आपको
क्या करना है? कस्टमाइज रिबन पे जाना है।
जाने के बाद आपको क्या करना है? डेवलपर
टैब पर टिक करना है। यह चीज सबको क्लियर
है? यह चीज सबको क्लियर है? बताइए। यह चीज
सबको क्लियर है? यह तब तक यह स्टेप
परफॉर्म नहीं करोगे तब तक आपका मै कोड रन
नहीं करेगा। बताइए यह चीज सबको क्लियर है?
मुझे जल्दी से बताइए चैट में यस या नो
मुझे यह बताओ।
चलिए उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है? उसके
बाद आपको जाना है किसके अंदर? ट्रस्ट
सेंटर के अंदर। उसके बाद आपको जाना है
ट्रस्ट सेंटर। ट्रस्ट सेंटर के अंदर आपको
क्या करना है? क्लिक करना है ट्रस्ट सेंटर
सेटिंग पर। उसके बाद आपको क्लिक करना है
ट्रस्ट सेंटर सेटिंग पर। दोबारा बता रहा
हूं। कस्टमाइज रिबन के बाद आपको जाना है
ट्रस्ट सेंटर पर। ट्रस्ट सेंटर पर जाकर
आपको ट्रस्ट सेंटर सेटिंग पर क्लिक करना
है। तो ट्रस्ट सेंटर सेटिंग पर क्लिक करने
के बाद आपको क्या करना है? आपके पास चार
ऑप्शन है। डिसेबल ऑल मैक्रोस विदाउट
नोटिफिकेशन। डिसेबल ऑल मैक विद
नोटिफिकेशन। डिसेबल ऑल मैक एक्सेप्ट
डिजिटली साइन मैक्रोज़ इनेबल ऑल मैक्रोज़
नॉट रिकमेंडेड तो आपको क्या करना है? पहले
से आपके में सेकंड ऑप्शन टिक होगा। तो
आपको क्या करना है? डिसेबल ऑल मैक्रोज़ विद
नोटिफिकेशन पे टिक करना है। अगर पहले से
है सेकंड ऑप्शन टिक तो आपको सेकंड ऑप्शन
ही सेलेक्ट रखना है। दूसरी चीज यहां पर
क्या करनी है आपको? ट्रस्ट एक्सेस टू द
वीबीए प्रोजेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल। यहां पर
टिक मार्क होना चाहिए। अनटिक नहीं टिक
होना चाहिए। अगर आपके में अनटिक है पहले
से तो आपको टिक करना है और अगर पहले से
टिक है तो आपको कुछ भी नहीं करना है।
अंडरस्टुड गाइज़? यह चीज समझ में आई? स्टेप
नंबर टू क्लियर है आपका?
स्टेप नंबर टू आपका क्लियर है?
स्टेप नंबर टू आपका क्लियर है।
स्टेप नंबर टू बताओ जल्दी से क्लियर है यह
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] स्टेप लिख
लिए सबने नोट डाउन कर लिए समझ में आया
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है ओके करना है
फिर से ओके करना है तो आपके में क्या होगा
जो स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है इधर यहां पर
एक टैब आ गया होगा ऊपर जैसे फाइल होम
इंसर्ट डिज़ाइन लेआउट रेफरेंस मेलिंग
रिव्यू व्यू और डेवलपर टैब अगर अगर आप मैक
इनेबल नहीं करते तो यह डेवलपर टैब आपके
पास नहीं आता। जो डेवलपर टैब दिखाई दे रहा
है आपको यह नहीं आता। यहां पर जो स्क्रीन
पे दिखाई दे रहा होगा। तो आपको अभी क्या
करना था? एक ब्लैंक डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन करना
है। ब्लैंक डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन करने के बाद
मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं कोपायलेट को।
उसके बाद आपको डेवलपर टैब में जाना है। जब
आप डेवलपर टैब में जाते हो तो यहां पर दो
ऑप्शन है। विजुअल बेसिक और मैक्रोज़। ठीक
है? आप विजुअल बेसिक से भी जाके भी इसको
क्या कर सकते हो? कर सकते हो। बट मैं आपको
ये एक ऑप्शन जो ज्यादातर आप यूज़ करते हो
उसके बारे में बताता हूं। विजुअल बेसिक पे
जाके वो चीज आप कर लेते हो लेकिन आपको एक
चीज समझ में नहीं आती जो मैं आपको बताने
की कोशिश करूंगा। तो अभी हम क्या करते
हैं? मैक पे क्लिक करते हैं। जैसे ही आपने
मैक पे क्लिक किया। यहां पर यह एक पॉपअप आ
गया। सबको पॉपअप दिखाई दे रहा है।
सबको पॉपअप दिखाई दे रहा है।
ठीक है। सबको एक पॉप अप दिखाई दे रहा है
इधर। एक मिनट 1 मिनट
सॉरी क्लोज कर देता हूं मैं इसको। क्लोज
कर देता हूं।
ठीक है? इसको मैं क्लोज कर काफी इसमें
बड़ा हो जाएगा। तो आपको समझ में नहीं
आएगा। ठीक है? तो आपको यहां पर यह पॉप
दिखाई दे रहा है।
पॉप अप यह रहा। तो यहां पर सबसे पहले क्या
है आपका? मैक नेम है। तो यहां पर आपको
लिखना है आपके मैक्रो का नाम जो आप क्रिएट
करना चाहते हो। जिस नाम से आप मैक क्रिएट
करना चाहते हो वो नाम लिखोगे। यहां पर
सवाल इसका नहीं है। अभी जो चीज मैं आपको
समझाने वाला हूं, सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है
आपके मैक डेवलपमेंट की। चाहे आप पेलोड
डेवलप कर रहे हो, चाहे आप नॉर्मल मैक कोड
लिख रहे हो। दोनों ही केस में अभी जो चीज
मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं, वो सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है। और हमारे एज ए
पेंटेस्टर बात कर रहे हैं तो उसकी बात
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] उसकी उसके
बारे में ही हम डिस्कस करेंगे। तो जब आप
एज ए पेंटेस्टर्स Microsoft Office
एप्लीकेशन में कोई भी मै कोड क्रिएट करते
हो। कोई भी मैक कोड चाहे वह मैकोड आप चाहे
मिलसियस मैकोड डेवलप कर रहे हो चाहे आप एक
नॉर्मल मैकोड डेवलप कर रहे हो तो एज ए
बिगिनर आप एक मेजर मिस्टेक करते हो एज ए
बिगिनर आप हमेशा एक मेजर मिस्टेक करते हो
मेजर मिस्टेक क्या होती है यहां पर आपको
एक कॉलम दिखाई दे रहा होगा मैक्रोज इन
यहां पर आपको एक कॉलम दिखाई दे रहा होगा
मैक्रोस इन और यहां पर मैं क्लिक करता हूं
ना यहां पर आपके पास चार ड्रॉपडाउन चार
लिस्ट आ रही है मतलब ड्रॉपडाउन लिस्ट में
चार ऑप्शंस आ रहे हैं आपके पास। यहां पर
आपके पास चार ऑप्शंस आ रहे हैं। और एज ए
बिगिनर आप क्या मिस्टेक करते हो? इस मैक
इन कॉलम के अंदर जो स्कोप है उसको आप सही
से सेलेक्ट नहीं करते। इसको इसके सिलेक्शन
में मिस्टेक करते हो। आप इसके सिलेक्शन
में मिस्टेक करते हो। किसके सेक्शन में?
इस मैक्रोज़ के मैक इन के सिलेक्शन में आप
मिस्टेक करते हो। और अगर आप
यहां पर जो चार ऑप्शंस है जिसको हम स्कोप
बोल रहे हैं अगर आप इसको सही से सेलेक्ट
नहीं करते तो क्या होगा
तो क्या होगा कि जब भी आप कोई भी मैक कोड
डेवलप करोगे और जो मैक कोड आपने किसके लिए
डेवलप किया है फॉर एग्जांपल इस पर्टिकुलर
फाइल के लिए मै डेवलप किया है आपने क्या
किया है इस सिंगल डॉक्यूमेंट के लिए मैक
डेवलपमेंट किया
तो क्या होगा कि अगर आपने यह स्कोप
सिलेक्शन सही से परफॉर्म नहीं किया या यह
स्कोप सेलेक्ट आपने सही से नहीं किया तो
क्या होगा कि जो माइक्रो कोड आपने डिजाइन
किया है वो इस सिंगल डॉक्यूमेंट तक
लिमिटेड रहने के बजाय क्या होगा जो पूरी
Microsoft Office एप्लीकेशन है जो आपकी
पूरी Microsoft एप्लीकेशन है खास करके
Microsoft Word से रिलेटेड ठीक है उसमें
स्प्रेड हो जाएगा फैल जाएगा उससे क्या
होगा उससे होगा यह कि जब भी आप क्या
करोगे? जब भी आप Microsoft Office ओपन
करोगे या जब भी आप Microsoft Word ओपन
करोगे तो क्या होगा कि उसके अंदर कोई भी
फाइल ओपन करो आप फॉर एग्जांपल अब जब भी
हमने क्या किया मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता
हूं। मैंने इसको क्लोज किया और इसको भी
मैंने क्लोज किया। अब मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं? Microsoft वर्ड ओपन कर रहा हूं। तो
यहां पर जब भी इनमें से कोई भी फाइल मैं
ओपन करूंगा जैसे ग्लोबल बैंक है एग्रीमेंट
नेटवर्क बैंक टेस्टिंग एटसेट्रा कोई भी
अगर मैं फाइल ओपन करने की कोशिश करूंगा तो
क्या होगा जो मै कोड आपने डिजाइन किया था
चाहे वो मशियस हो चाहे आप नॉन मलेशियस हो
जो भी मै कोड आपने डिजाइन किया था वो क्या
होगा वो हर एक फाइल के साथ रन करेगा
इसलिए ऑलवेज रिमेंबर मै कोड डेवलपमेंट के
दौरान आपको स्कोप सिलेक्शन सही से परफॉर्म
करना है। यह जो स्कोप सिलेक्शन है आपको
यहां पर इसको सही से परफॉर्म करना है। इन
चारों ऑप्शंस में से जो कौन सा ऑप्शन का
क्या मतलब वो तो मैं आपको बताऊंगा लेकिन
यह जो स्कोप सिलेक्शन है इसको सही से
परफॉर्म करना है जब कोई भी आप मै
डेवलपमेंट कर रहे हो। अब सवाल यह उठता है
कि सही स्कोप सिलेक्शन कैसे करें? अब आपके
मन में जो सवाल है बिल्कुल जायज सवाल है
कि हम सर सही स्कोप सिलेक्शन कैसे करेंगे?
अगर आपको सही स्कोप सिलेक्शन करना है तो
आपको क्या करना होगा? इन चारों ऑप्शन को
सही से समझना होगा। हर एक ऑप्शन का क्या
मतलब है यहां पर? तभी आप अपना स्कोप
सिलेक्शन सही से परफॉर्म कर पाओगे।
अंडरस्टुड गाइज़? क्या बताने की कोशिश कर
रहा हूं? आपको चीज समझ में आ रही है कि
मैं आपको क्या बताने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं
कि अगर आपने यह स्कोप सिलेक्शन सही
परफॉर्म नहीं किया तो आपका जो मै कोड है
वह सही से काम नहीं करेगा। ठीक है? आपको
लगता है कि आपने माइक्रो कोड सही डिजाइन
किया है बट वह सही से काम नहीं करेगा या
आपने किसी एक पर्टिकुलर फाइल के लिए
डिजाइन किया है वह सभी फाइल के साथ
एग्जीक्यूट होगा अंडरस्टुड तो इसलिए सबसे
पहली रिस्पांसिबिलिटी आपकी क्या है कि जब
आप कोड लिखोगे कोड लिखने से भी पहले आपकी
एक सब फर्स्ट रिस्पांसिबिलिटी बनती है कि
ये जो चार ऑप्शंस हैं इन चारों ऑप्शंस में
से आपका जो स्कोप सिलेक्शन है वो 100% सही
होना चाहिए। अगर यहां पर आपने गलती की तो
फिर बाकी के जो स्टेप्स हैं बाकी आप कोई
भी कोड लिख रहे हो आप किसी के किसी के लिए
कितना भी अच्छा कोड लिख लो यहां की
मिस्टेक आपको बाद में प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट
करने वाली है 100%
आपको प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट करने वाली है। तो
चलिए फिर एक काम करते हैं। हम स्लाइड पर
चलते हैं और इस ऑप्शन को समझने की कोशिश
करते हैं। तो चलिए फिर हम ये ऑप्शन समझते
हैं। तो कैसे समझते हैं? तो जब भी आप क्या
करते हो Microsoft Office Word में जैसा
कि मैंने आपको अभी बताया था जब भी आप क्या
करते हो Microsoft Office Word में Micro
टैब ओपन करते हो जैसे मैंने आपको यहां पर
दिखाया डेवलपर टैब उसके बाद मैक्रोस क्लिक
किया और यहां पर आपको एक पॉपअप दिखाई देता
है तो जब भी आप क्या करते हो
यह मै कोड सिलेक्शन करते हो तो आप आपके
सामने एक पॉपअप आता है पॉपअप में आप जो मै
इन टैब है यहां पर आप दिखाई दे रहा है
आपको मै इन टैब अभी तो दिखाई दे रहा होगा
शायद आपको जो मै इन टैब है इसके अंदर अंदर
आपको चार ऑप्शंस दिखाई देते हैं। इसके
अंदर आपको चार ऑप्शंस दिखाई देते हैं। आई
होप सबको यहां पर दिखाई दे रहा होगा।
व्हेन यू ओपन द मैक्रोस टैब इन microsoft
ऑफिस वर्ड द मैक इन ड्रॉपडाउन मेनू
प्रेजेंट फॉर ऑप्शंस।
सबको दिखाई दे रहा है? सबको क्लियरली
दिखाई दे रहा है। आपको चार ऑप्शंस दिखाई
देते हैं यहां पर। ठीक है? तो चारों
ऑप्शंस के बारे में हम समझते हैं। तो सबसे
पहले हम समझते हैं अपना फर्स्ट ऑप्शन ऑल
एक्टिव टेंप्लेट्स एंड डॉक्यूमेंट। तो आइए
आइए सबसे पहले हम समझते हैं कि जब भी हम
Microsoft Office Word में माइक्रो टैब
ओपन करते हैं तो सबसे पहला ऑप्शन आपको कौन
सा दिखाई देता है? तो सबसे पहला ऑप्शन
आपको कौन सा दिखाई देता है? ऑल एक्टिव
टेंपल्लेट्स एंड डॉक्यूमेंट्स। कौन सा?
सबसे पहला ऑप्शन आपको कौन सा दिखाई देता
है? ऑल एक्टिव टेंप्लेट्स एंड
डॉक्यूमेंट्स। अब यह क्यों दिया गया है?
और इसको कब यूज़ करना चाहिए? इसके बारे में
बात करने वाले हैं कि यह ऑप्शन क्यों दिया
गया है और इसको कब यूज करना चाहिए इसके
बारे में बात करेंगे और इसके बारे में बात
करने से पहले मैं एक चीज बता देता हूं अगर
हम आसान भाषा में बात करें कि इसको हम
क्या बोलते हैं यूनिवर्सल मास्टर लिस्ट या
कंबाइंड एग्रीगेटर व्यू भी इसको बोला जाता
है। इसको अगर कई बार इसको क्या क्या बोला
जाता है? जो ऑल एक्टिव टेंपलेट या
डॉक्यूमेंट ऑप्शन है इसको यूनिवर्सल
मास्टर लिस्ट और कंबाइंड एग्रीगेटर व्यू
भी बोला जाता है। ओके कंबाइंड एग्रीगेटर
व्यू भी इसको आप बोल सकते हो। इसलिए जब भी
आप क्या करते हो
इसलिए जब भी आप क्या करते हो? Microsoft
Word वर्ड ओपन करते हो तो Microsoft Word
के साथ मल्टीपल फाइल्स आपकी क्या हो जाती
है? लोड हो सकती हैं। ठीक है? अभी मेरा
पीसी है। मेरे पीसी में मल्टीपल फाइल्स
देखो आपको एक लिस्ट यहां पर दिखाई दी थी।
ठीक है? आपके सामने एक लिस्ट दिखाई दी थी
ना वहां पर तो मल्टीपल फाइल्स लोड हो गई।
ऐसे ही अगर आप किसी कंपनी में काम कर रहे
होगे जहां पर सबसे ज्यादा यूज़ होता है
Microsoft Word, एक्सेल इन सबका ज्यादा
यूज़ होता है। तो उनके पास तो क्या है?
100्स ऑफ फाइल्स होती हैं। 50 फाइल्स होती
हैं। और भी बहुत ज्यादा फाइल्स होती हैं
जो क्या होता है?
क्या होता है? बहुत सारी फाइल्स होती हैं।
तो वो सारी क्या होती है? Microsoft Word
के अंदर क्या हो जाती है? लोड हो जाती है।
ठीक है? अब वो हो सकता है आपके करंट
डॉक्यूमेंट हो सकती है। आपके ग्लोबल
टेंपलेट हो सकती है या फिर वो आपकी क्या
होती है? कस्टम टेंपलेट हो सकती है। और जब
आप क्या करते हो? जैसे कि आप स्क्रीन पर
दिखाई दे रहा है आपको। जब आप ऑल एक्टिव
टेंपलेट या डॉक्यूमेंट्स पर क्लिक करते हो
करंट डॉक्यूमेंट में तो आपका जो Microsoft
Word है इन सभी लोकेशनेशंस को स्कैन करता
है। कौन-कौन सी लोकेशन? आपकी करंट
डॉक्यूमेंट, आपका ग्लोबल टेंपलेट या फिर
आपका कस्टम टेंपलेट। यह जितने भी
लोकेशनेशंस हैं, मैं आपको यहां पर सेलेक्ट
कर ले यह रहा। ठीक है? चाहे आपका करंट
डॉक्यूमेंट है, आपका ग्लोबल टेंपलेट है या
कस्टम डॉक्यूमेंट है। आपका जब भी आप क्या
करते हैं? ऑल एक्टिव टेंपलेट या
डॉक्यूमेंट्स को क्या करते हो? सेलेक्ट
करते हो तो क्या होता है कि जो Microsoft
Word है इन सारी एक्टिव लोकेशनेशंस को
स्कैन करता है और स्कैन करने के बाद स्कैन
करने के बाद
इन सभी में मौजूद जितने भी मैक्रोस कोड
हैं उन सबको क्या करता है? एक सिंगल
कंबाइंड लिस्ट में आपके सामने स्क्रीन में
शो करता है। अब मेरे केस में खाली था।
खाली क्यों था? क्योंकि मेरी किसी भी फाइल
में मैक कोड ही नहीं है। किसी भी फाइल में
हमने कोई भी मै कोड नहीं लिखा हुआ है।
इसलिए मेरे केस में वो खाली है। बट यहां
पर मैंने जो एग्जांपल लिया है यहां पर
आपको देखो क्लीन अप वन क्लीन अप टू क्लीन
अप थ्री मै वन मै टू इस तरीके से आपको
ऑप्शन दिखाई दे रहे हैं। क्योंकि इसने
क्या किया जो आपकी कस्टम आपका कस्टम
टेंपलेट थी या आपकी जो ग्लोबल टेंपलेट थी
या जो करंट डॉक्यूमेंट थे इन सबको स्कैन
किया। स्कैन करने के बाद एक कंबाइंड लिस्ट
आपके सामने स्क्रीन पे शो कर दिया कि लो
भाई इतने सारे मैक कोड आपके सिस्टम में
क्या है अवेलेबल्स हैं। ये कंबाइन लिस्ट
इसने शो कर दी। तो अभी जो चीज मैंने आपको
बताई ये था इसका फीचर। ये इसका क्या है?
फीचर है कि यह जो ऑप्शन है क्या करता है?
बट अब हम बात करते हैं कि हम इसको कैसे
यूज कर सकते हैं।
बोला सर आपने फीचर बता दिया बट एज ए
पेंटस्टर्स हम इसको कैसे यूज कर सकते हैं?
इसकी बात करते हैं। तो अगर आप यह चेक करना
चाहते हैं कि फिलहाल आपके माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
वर्ड एनवायरमेंट में कितने मैक्रोच लोडेड
हैं?
फिलहाल आपके माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड एनवायरमेंट
में कितने मैक्रोच लोडेड हैं? चाहे वो ओपन
डॉक्यूमेंट के हो, चाहे वो ग्लोबल टेंपलेट
के हो। तो आप इस ऑप्शन का यूज कर सकते हो।
ठीक है? इफ यू वांट टू क्विकली चेक हाउ
मेनी टोटल मैक्रोस आर करेंटली लोडेड इन
योर माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड एनवायरमेंट तो आप
क्या कर सकते हो? इस ऑप्शन का यूज कर सकते
हो। ठीक है? अब बात करते हैं बिगिनियर्स
की। बिगिनर्स अक्सर क्या मिस्टेक करते
हैं? चलो मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकली दिखा देता
हूं। देखो
आपने जैसे क्या किया था? डेवलपर पर गए।
मैस क्लिक किया। ठीक है? डेवलपर पर गए।
मैं इसको पहले क्लोज करता हूं। यह रहा
डेवलप ऑप्शन गए। मैक्रोस पर क्लिक करते
हैं। व्हाट हैपन ब्रो? चलो मैं इसको पूरा
ही क्लोज कर देता हूं। एंड फिर से हम इसको
टैब जाते हैं। ओके। ओपन नहीं है ये। इट्स
ओके। हम इसको मिनिमाइज करते हैं। इसको
मिनिमाइज करते हैं। देन गो टू अ वर्ड एंड
देन गो टू ब्लैंक डॉक्यूमेंट। गो टू
डेवलपर टैब मैक्रोस। क्लिक किया। यहां पर
नाम लिख लिया आपने। फॉर एग्जांपल टेस्ट
मैक्रो
टेस्ट मैक्रो आपने लिख लिया भाई बात ऐसी
है। अब आप क्या करोगे? इतना किए और यहां
पर क्रिएट पे क्लिक कर दोगे। ठीक है? अब
मिस्टेक क्या करते हो कि आपने डायरेक्टली
क्या किया कि यह जो ऑप्शन है ना ऑल एक्टिव
टेंपल्लेट्स एंड डॉक्यूमेंट इसके साथ ही
आपने क्या कर दिया? इसको क्रिएट कर दिया।
और यही आपकी सबसे बड़ी मिस्टेक होती है।
यही आपकी सबसे बड़ी मिस्टेक है। यह आपको
नहीं करना है। लिख लो कहीं पर भी आपको
यह ऑप्शन यूज़ नहीं करना है। ड्यूरिंग
क्रिएशन और सिलेक्शन। ठीक है? समझ में आ
गया गाइज? होल्ड ऑन गाइज। गिव मी 2 मिनट।
होल्ड ऑन गाइस।
सॉरी गाइस मुझे थोड़ा सा नहीं है आपको
क्लास थोड़ी सी मुझे दो या 3 मिनट के लिए
मेरे को एक अर्जेंट कॉल करना होगा। तो वह
मैं करके आपको दोबारा अटेंड करूंगा। तो तब
तक के लिए मैं इसको कांसेप्ट को क्लियर कर
देता हूं। आपको मैंने क्या बताया? आपको यह
ऑप्शन यूज़ नहीं करना है। ठीक है? आपको यह
ऑप्शन यूज़ नहीं करना है। क्योंकि यह जो
ऑप्शन है, आपको सिर्फ किस पर्पज के लिए
दिया गया है? यह ऑप्शन सिर्फ आपको फिल्टर
पर्पज के लिए दिया गया है। आपका जो ऑप्शन
है ये आपको सिर्फ एक फिल्टर पर्पज से दिया
गया है। ठीक है? आपको सिर्फ किस पर्पस से
दिया गया है? आपको सिर्फ फ़्टर पर्पस से
आपको दिया गया है। जैसे आपको स्क्रीन पे
यहां पे दिखाई दे रहा है। ये कॉमन मिस्टेक
है जो क्या करते हैं? बिगिनर्स करते हैं।
तो इसलिए आपको ये चीज ध्यान में रखनी है।
ठीक है? ये चीज ध्यान में नहीं। अब आप
बोलोगे सर अगर मैंने ऐसा कर भी दिया तो हो
क्या रहा है? अगर आपने ऐसा कर भी दिया तो
क्या हो रहा है कि Microsoft डज़ नॉट रिसीव
ए क्लियर डायरेक्शन ऑन वेयर टू सेव द कोड
वेदर इट शुड गो इंटू योर टारगेट
डॉक्यूमेंट। मतलब यह है कि अगर आपने इस
ऑप्शन के साथ अगर आपने क्रिएट बटन दबा
दिया तो जो Microsoft Word है उसको यह
क्लियर डायरेक्शन नहीं मिलती कि जो कोड
आपने बनाया है जो आप कोड लिखने वाले हो
वो आपको आपका जो Microsoft है उसको कहां
पर सेव करें। क्या उसको करंट डॉक्यूमेंट
में सेव करना है या फिर आपकी जो सिस्टम की
ग्लोबल टेंपलेट होती है एक मैं बताऊंगा
ग्लोबल टेंपलेट जो सेकंड ऑप्शन दिखाई दे
रहा है यहां पर नॉर्मल डॉट डॉट ग्लोबल
टेंपलेट इसमें सेव करना है या जिस करंट
डॉक्यूमेंट में आप काम कर रहे हो इसमें
सेव करना है ठीक है इस चीज में क्या होता
है आपका जो वो है मैक वो क्या होता है
कंफ्यूज हो जाता है इस चीज में कंफ्यूज हो
जाता है इसलिए एज ए रिजल्ट देयर इज़ अ हाई
चांस दैट योर मै कोड विल बी सेव्ड लोकली
इनसाइड योर कंप्यूटरटर्स ग्लोबल सिस्टम
टेंपलेट। इसलिए सबसे ज्यादा हाई चांस यह
होते हैं जब आप यह ऑप्शन सेलेक्ट करते हो
तो आपका जो माइक्रो कोड है आपके कंप्यूटर
के अंदर लोकली जो सिस्टम की जो ग्लोबल
टेंपलेट है किसकी? आपके माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस
की। उसकी ग्लोबल टेंपलेट में उसको क्या कर
देता है? सेव कर देता है। किसकी बजाय? जो
टारगेट डॉक्यूमेंट है जिसके लिए आपने उसको
डिजाइन किया गया है जिसके आप भेजने वाले
हो फॉर एग्जांपल आपका टारगेट किसी एंप्लई
है उस एंप्लई में आप क्या करो कोड मैक कोड
आपने क्या किया डिजाइन किया मिलिसिस कोड
और आप उसको भेजने वाले हो उसकी टेंपलेट
में सेव होने के बजाय उसके डॉक्यूमेंट में
सेव होने के बजाय आप ही के सिस्टम पर जो
ग्लोबल टेंपलेट है उसके अंदर क्या हो
जाएगा वह सेव हो जाएगा उसके अंदर चला
जाएगा अब इससे होगा क्या इससे से होगा यह
कि जब भी आप डॉक्यूमेंट को किसी भी
विक्टिम या किसी भी फॉर एग्जांपल
प्रैक्टिकल के आप अपने टारगेट वर्चुअल
मशीन पर भेजोगे तो क्या होगा जो वो मैक
कोड है वो आप ही के सिस्टम पर क्या हो
जाएगा रह जाएगा और जो टारगेट फाइल है जो
टारगेट के पास जो फाइल जाएगी उसके पास वह
एम्प्टी फाइल जाएगी गिव मी गाइस मुझे 2
मिनट का टाइम दीजिए बस मैं 2 मिनट में आता
हूं आपके पास तब तक के लिए प्लीज प्लीज 2
मिनट का टाइम
हेलो एवरीवन ओके आई एम बैक
ओके थैंक यू फॉर वेटिंग
चलिए फिर कंटिन्यू करें। यहां तक सबको समझ
में आ गया। मैं आपको जो बता रहा था
यहां तक सबको सब कुछ समझ में आ गया जो
मैंने आपको बताया कि आपको क्या नहीं करना
और क्या क्या नहीं करना है कि इस ऑप्शन को
सेलेक्ट नहीं करना है। क्योंकि ये ऑप्शन
जब आप सेलेक्ट करते हो क्रिएट करते हो तो
उसकी वजह से क्या होता है कि आपका जो
Microsoft Office वो कंफ्यूज हो जाता है
कि मुझे इसको सेव कहां पर करना है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
तो इसलिए एक गोल्डन रूल है आप लोगों के
लिए। आपको कभी भी नहीं बोलना है। कि
सर्चिंग के लिए आपको ऑल एक्टिव टेंपलेट्स
या डॉक्यूमेंट्स को आप यूज कर सकते हो।
अगर आपको यह सर्च करना है आपके सिस्टम के
अंदर कितने माइक्रो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
जो कोड है इनेबल्स है। कितने माइक्रो कोड
मतलब आपने डेवलप किए हुए हैं। यह देखने के
लिए सर्चिंग पर्पस के लिए आप क्या कर सकते
हो?
इस ऑप्शन का यूज़ कर सकते हो। लेकिन आपको
कभी भी कोई भी डॉक्यूमेंट क्रिएट करने के
लिए या कोई भी डॉक्यूमेंट सेव करने के लिए
मतलब फॉर एग्जांपल कोई भी मै कोड क्रिएट
करने के लिए डिजाइन करने के लिए उसको सेव
करने के लिए आपको इस ऑप्शन को यूज़ नहीं
करना है।
इस ऑप्शन को यूज़ नहीं करना है। इसको भूल
जाओ। हमें इसलिए भूलना है बिकॉज़ वी आर द
बिगिनर्स। हमारा इसका कोई काम नहीं है। हम
इसको नहीं यूज करने वाले। ठीक है? तो हमें
इसको
हमेशा ध्यान रखना है यह ऑप्शन बाय डिफॉल्ट
रहता है। इसको चेंज करना है। याद रहेगा यह
चीज? यह चीज आप लोगों को याद रहेगी।
चलिए ठीक है? नेक्स्ट पॉइंट पर चलते हैं
हम। पॉइंट नंबर टू कौन सा आपका?
नॉर्मल डॉट m नॉर्मल डॉट m जिसको हम
ग्लोबल टेंपलेट भी बोलते हैं। पॉइंट नंबर
टू कौन सा आपका जो ऑप्शन नंबर टू है स्कोप
नंबर टू आपका क्या है? नॉर्मल डॉट। ठीक
है? अभी यह क्या है? इसके बारे में जानते
हैं। अगर आप कोई ऐसा मैक कोड डिजाइन करना
चाहते हो या कोई ऐसा मै कोड बनाना चाहते
हो। ठीक है? और यह यह भी मैं बता देता हूं
आप आपके लिए। यह भी हमारे काम का नहीं है।
खासकर ड्यूरिंग पेलोड डेवलपमेंट। ठीक है?
क्यों नहीं है? मैं आपको बता दूंगा। बट यह
कब काम का है वो आपको फाइंड आउट करना
होगा। इसके लिए मैं आप लोगों को एक टास्क
दूंगा। तो अगर आप कोई ऐसा माइक्रो कोड
डिजाइन करना चाहते हो जो आपके सिस्टम पर
हमेशा और हर एक वर्ड टाइम मतलब आपके
सिस्टम पर हमेशा और हर एक वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट
में अवेलेबल हो। याद रखो यह पॉइंट कि आप
चाहते हो कि आपके सिस्टम पर हमेशा और हर
एक वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट के लिए वो अवेलेबल हो
तभी आप इस ऑप्शन का यूज़ कर सकते हो।
इस ऑप्शन की कंडीशन समझ में आया कि सारे
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड के अंदर वह काम करना
करेगा और आपके सिस्टम पर हमेशा के लिए अगर
कोई आप ऐसी स्क्रिप्ट लिखना चाहते हो ऐसा
कोई पेलोड भी डिजाइन करना चाहते हो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तभी आपको इस
ऑप्शन को यूज करना है। अदरवाइज यह ऑप्शन
आपके काम का नहीं है। तो भाई यह है क्या
चीज? तो मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करता हूं। तो
यह क्या चीज है? मैं आपको बता देता हूं।
नेक्स्ट नॉर्मल इज द मेन सिस्टम टेंपलेट
फॉर microsoft word जो नॉर्मल डॉट है आपके
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड का मेन सिस्टम टेंपलेट
होता है। इफ यू सेव इफ यू सेव योर
माइक्रोकोड इन दिस टेंपलेट। अगर आप अपना
माइक्रोकोड इसमें सेव करते हो तो क्या
होगा? आप जब भी पीसी पर कोई भी
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड खोलोगे या कोई भी
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड फाइल ओपन करोगे तो आपका
यह माइक्रो कोड हर एक नई या पुरानी फाइल
में क्या होगा? रन करेगा। आई एम रिपीटिंग
अगेन कि इससे क्या होगा कि अगर आपने यह
ऑप्शन सेलेक्ट किया है और आपने अगर अपना
माइक्रो कोड डिजाइन किया है तो जब भी पीसी
पर आप Microsoft Word में कोई भी फाइल ओपन
करोगे चाहे वह नई फाइल हो चाहे पुरानी
फाइल हो सब में यह कोड काम करेगा बिकॉज़ यह
जो नॉर्मल है यह आपके Microsoft Word की
क्या है क्या है आपकी Microsoft Word की
ग्लोबल टेंपलेट है। और आप जो मै कोड किसके
अंदर बना रहे हो? ग्लोबल टेंपलेट के अंदर।
और ग्लोबल का मतलब क्या है? सभी के लिए
काम करने वाली टेंपलेट। अंडरस्टुड?
अंडरस्टुड? यह ऑप्शन किस पर्पस से है? और
इस ऑप्शन का क्या काम है? बस यही इसका काम
है। लेकिन इसके एक लिमिटेशंस है। बट
रिमेंबर
अगर आप यह डॉक्यूमेंट अगर आपने अपना पेलोड
बनाया आपने पेलोड बनाया, मिलिशियस फाइल
बनाई या आपने एक नॉर्मल ही मै कोड क्यों
ना डिजाइन किया हो और आपने इस ऑप्शन के
साथ उसको डिजाइन किया है। और डिजाइन करने
के बाद अगर आपने यह डॉक्यूमेंट किसी
फ्रेंड, किसी कलीग या किसी क्लाइंट को मेल
किया। ठीक है? और जैसे ही वह आपका फ्रेंड,
आपका क्लाइंट या आपका कलीग उस फाइल को ओपन
करता है, तो वह मैक कोड उसके पीसी पर नहीं
रन करेगा। क्योंकि जो आपने कोड डिजाइन
किया था वो आपने आपके खुद के सिस्टम की
ग्लोबल टेंपलेट के अंदर डिजाइन किया था ना
कि आपके टारगेट सिस्टम के ग्लोबल टेंपलेट
के अंदर। तो यही वह कारण है कि अगर आपने
इस ऑप्शन के साथ भी मिलसियस फाइल डिजाइन
की, माइक्रो कोड डिजाइन किया और फिर आपने
उसको टारगेट सिस्टम के पास या विक्टिम के
पास भेजा तब भी वह कोड काम नहीं करेगा।
क्यों काम नहीं करेगा? क्योंकि जो वो कोड
आपने डिजाइन किया वो आपने अपने सिस्टम के
लिए तो डिजाइन कर लिया बट टारगेट सिस्टम
के पास वो गया ही नहीं क्योंकि वो आपके
ग्लोबल टेंपलेट में था ना कि टारगेट के
ग्लोबल टेंपलेट में।
पॉइंट नंबर टू भी क्लियर है? पॉइंट नंबर
टू भी क्लियर है आपका?
देखो सारी चीजें एक-एक चीजें क्लियर कर
लो। बिकॉज़ मिस्टेक नहीं होनी चाहिए।
मिस्टेक आपको फिर क्या है कि आपको बहुत
परेशान करेंगी। आपका बहुत टाइम वेस्ट हो
जाएगा। तो बताओ जल्दी से। अंडरस्टुड? मजा
आ रहा है क्लास में? सीखने को मिल रहा है
कुछ? और यह मत सोचना कि सर प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन में क्या चल रहा है? यह प्रैक्टिकल
ही है। कुछ भी इसमें नहीं है। क्योंकि
जो चीज आप करने वाले हो उससे पहले उसका
बेसिक तो पता होना चाहिए ना। कर क्या रहे
हो? अंडरस्टुड?
करप्ट नहीं होगा भाई करप्ट नहीं होगा वो
आपके पास ही रहेगी वह आपके उसके पास
टारगेट के पास नहीं जाएगी
इस केस में आपके टारगेट के पास आपका मैक
कोड नहीं जाएगा एम एम्प्टी जाएगा बाकी सब
कुछ जाएगा बट मै कोड नहीं जाएगा
मै कोड नहीं जाने वाला तो अभी हम आते हैं
किसके पॉइंट नंबर थ्री पर ठीक है अब आएंगे
हम पॉइंट नंबर थ्री पर तो पॉइंट नंबर थ्री
पर हम प्रैक्टिकली ही आते हैं तो यह है
आपका पॉइंट नंबर थ्री पॉइंट नंबर थ्री कौन
सा आपका वर्ड कमांड्स आपका स्कोप नंबर
थ्री है आपका वर्ड कमांड्स और जैसे मैंने
इस पर क्लिक किया अभी देखो
देखो क्या-क्या खुल रहा है। हेल्प
कांटेक्ट अस हेल्प टूल ये सारी चीजें ये
क्या चीज है मैं आपको बताता हूं।
देखो Microsoft Word में आप कोई भी बेसिक
ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म करते हो जैसे आप फाइल को
सेव करना, फाइल को प्रिंट करना,
डॉक्यूमेंट क्लोज करना। तो बैकग्राउंड में
क्या होता है? बैकग्राउंड में Microsoft
Word अपने खुद के प्रीडफाइंड इंटरनल मैक
कोड रन करता है।
जब भी आप कोई भी बेसिक ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म
करते हो चाहे वो कंट्रोल एस करते हो,
कंट्रोल पी करते हो, फाइल को क्लोज करते
हो। फाइल को क्लोज करने के लिए मैं यहां
पर क्रॉस पर करता हूं। क्वेश्चन मार्क
हेल्प फाइल देखने के लिए यह करता हूं। मैं
व्यू यह करने के लिए जैसे सेव करने के लिए
यहां पर एक ऑप्शन होता है। तो सब पर क्लिक
करता हूं। तो ये सारे ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म करने
के लिए जो आपका Microsoft Word है या जो
Microsoft Office है वो क्या करता है? खुद
के प्रीडफाइंड इंटरनल मैक कोड को रन करता
है यह सारे टास्क परफॉर्म करने के लिए।
क्योंकि यह इसके बिल्ट इन फंक्शनंस होते
हैं। ठीक है? ठीक है? वो इसके बिल्ट इन
फंक्शनंस होते हैं। और जितने भी बिल्ट इन
फंक्शनंस होते हैं उनको बोला जाता है वर्ड
कमांड्स। उनको क्या बोला जाता है? वर्ड
कमांड्स।
क्या बोला जाता है उनको? वर्ड कमांड्स।
फॉर एग्जांपल्स जैसे कि मैं एक एग्जांपल
दिखाता हूं। यहां पर देखो फॉर एग्जांपल्स
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। वर्ड कमांड्स में
जब आपको फाइल सेव करते हो यहां पर एफ पे आ
जाते हैं। जे के एल एम एन ओ ए बी सी डी ई
एफ एफ एफ एफ
यह रहा। यह रहा यह रहा। यह
क्योंकि वह चीज आपको ज्यादा अच्छे समझ में
आएगी जो आपको इजी है। देखो फाइल सेव एज
है। सेव एज आप यूज़ करते हो। ठीक है? सेव
एज कॉपी फाइल सेव ये क्या करता है? जो
फाइल सेव है या जो फाइल सेव एज क्या है?
जब भी आप फाइल को क्या करते हो? सेव करते
हो तब यह यह जो इनबिल्ट फंक्शनंस दिखाई दे
रहा है ना आपको यह जो वर्ड कमांड है यह
ट्रिगर होते हैं या जब आप क्या करते हो
इसमें फाइल प्रिंट होगा जैसे कि एक फाइल
प्रिंट भी होगा यहां पर एक फाइल प्रिंट
फाइल न्यू न्यू फाइल ओपन करते हो फाइल ओपन
करते हो तो यह ट्रिगर होता है ऐसे ही फाइल
क्लोज ऑल फाइल क्लोज ठीक है फाइल चेक इन
ठीक है ऐसे बहुत सारे आपके क्या है बिल्ट
इन फंक्शनंस होते हैं जो आप क्या करते हो
परफॉर्म करते हो। ठीक है? अब नॉर्मल यूजर
के केस में आपको क्या दिखता है? नॉर्मल
यूजर इंटरफ़ेस में आपको यह जो कमांड्स है
या तो किसी बटन के फॉर्म में दिए गए हैं
या फिर आपको क्या किया गया है? जीयूआई के
फॉर्म में आपको कहीं ना कहीं वो दिखाई
देते हैं। ठीक है? जैसे यहां पर क्रॉस बटन
दिखाई दे रहा है। ये कर दिया। उसके बाद
यहां पर देखोगे यहां पर ये सेव के लिए ये
रहा। कंट्रोल एस सेव है। इंसर्ट डिज़ ऐसे।
ठीक है? ये रहा। ठीक है? जैसे ब्लैंक पेज,
पेज ब्रेक। तो ऐसे आपको क्या है? जीआई की
फॉर्म में चीजें दिखते हैं। लेकिन
बैकग्राउंड में क्या हो रहा है? Microsoft
Word क्या कर रहा है? अपने जो विजुअल
बेसिक स्क्रिप्ट यूज़ कर रहा है। जो विजुअल
बेसिक के बिल्ट इन फंक्शनंस हैं उनका यूज़
कर रहा है। ठीक है? आपका क्या कर रहा है?
बिल्ट इन फंक्शनंस का यूज़ कर रहा है। और
जब आप क्या करते हो? जब आपने क्या किया?
यहां पर डेवलपर टैब पर गए और आपने यहां पर
क्या किया? क्लिक किया। जब आप क्या करते
हो? जब वर्ड कमांड को सेलेक्ट करते हो तो
आपके सामने क्या होता है कि आपके
जो Microsoft Word के अंदर जितने भी
इंटरनल कमांड्स हैं उनकी सारी लिस्ट आपको
यहां पर दिखाई दे रही है। यह सारी वही
लिस्ट है जितनी भी इंटरनल कमांड्स हैं जो
आप परफॉर्म करते हो Microsoft Word के
अंदर तो वह सारे के सारे जो फंक्शनंस की
जो इंटरनल कमांड है वर्ड कमांड है जो
इनबिल्ट फंक्शनंस है उनकी जो सारी लिस्ट
है आपको यहां पर देखने को मिलती है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन वो सारी लिस्ट आपको यहां
पर देखने को मिलती है।
चीज समझ में आई कि जो वर्ड कमांड का पर्पस
क्या है? वर्ड कमांड किस लिए दिया गया है
कि आपके Microsoft Word के अंदर जितने भी
इंटरनल कमांड्स हैं उसकी सारी लिस्ट अगर
आपको देखनी है तो वह आप इस ऑप्शन को या इस
स्कोप को सेलेक्ट करके देख सकते हो। अब
भाई एज ए पेंटेस्टर्स
हम हमारे लिए क्या है? तो एज ए
पेंटेस्टर्स मैं आपको बताता हूं कि हम
इसके साथ क्या कर सकते हैं। डोंट ट्राई
इट। तो इसलिए
आपको एक चीज याद रखनी है क्या?
कि
आप क्या कर सकते हो? आप किसी भी एक कमांड
को सेलेक्ट करके फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या
किया? एक सेव एज कमांड है। मैंने इसको
सेलेक्ट किया। किसी भी एक कमांड को
सेलेक्ट करके सेम फंक्शन नेम से। ठीक है?
आप क्या कर सकते हो? इसके अंदर कुछ भी
नहीं कर सकते। आप मॉडिफाई एडिट नहीं कर
सकते। बट आप क्या कर सकते हो? सेम फाइल
नेम जैसे फाइल सेव है सेम फाइल नेम से खुद
का एक नया मै क्रिएट कर सकते हो एग्जैक्ट
सेम नेम से ठीक है एग्जैक्ट सेम नेम से
नया मै कोड क्या कर सकते हो आप क्रिएट कर
सकते हो क्रिएट करने के बाद क्या कर सकते
हो आप उसको हाईजैक कर सकते हो क्योंकि
आपने क्या किया कंट्रोल एस का जो कोड था
उसको सेम उसका जो नेम था सेम नेम उठाया
आपने एक मै कोड लिखा और किसको भेज दिया
यूजर को टारगेट यूजर को भेज दिया। तो जब
भी टारगेट यूजर कंट्रोल एस परफॉर्म करेगा
तो वह क्या करेगा? वह आपका जो कोड लिखा
आपने वह उसको परफॉर्म करेगा ना कि जो इसका
बाय डिफॉल्ट वाला कोड था। ठीक है? क्योंकि
इसका डिफॉल्ट बिहेवियर क्या होता है कि
पहले जो कोड लिखा गया है वह एग्जीक्यूट
होता है। उसके बाद डिफॉल्ट कोड एग्जीक्यूट
होता है। इसी वजह से आप क्या कर सकते हो?
इसके डिफॉल्ट बिहेवियर को हाईजैक भी कर
सकते हो। अब बात करते हैं रेड टीम
इंगेजमेंट में। ठीक है? रेटिम इंगेजमेंट
में आप वर्ड कमांड्स को दो प्राइमरी रीजन
से यूज करते हो। ठीक है? इसके दो प्राइमरी
रीज़ंस है जिनसे जिन रीजन के लिए जिन
कारणों से आप क्या करते हो? इसका यूज़ करते
हो। पहला प्राइमरी रीजन है पर्सिस्टेंस
मैकेनिज्म। पहला प्राइमरी रीज़न क्या है
आपका? पर्सिस्टेंस मैकेनिज्म। मतलब एन
अटैकर्स ओवराइड कॉमन कमांड्स इनसाइड द
टारगेट सिस्टम्स ग्लोबल टेंपलेट मतलब क्या
करता है कि जो अटैकर्स है टारगेट सिस्टम्स
के जो ग्लोबल टेंपलेट होती है ग्लोबल
टेंपलेट में जो कॉमन कमांड्स है जैसे कि
आपका कंट्रोल एस हो गया कंट्रोल पी हो गया
आपका सेव एज हो गया या फाइल प्रिंट हो गया
उसको क्या कर सकता है ओवराइड कर सकता है
जिसका इंपैक्ट क्या होगा उसका इंपैक्ट
क्या क्या होगा? जब भी यूजर फ्यूचर में
कोई भी नॉर्मल वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट सेव या
प्रिंट करेगा। इंपैक्ट की बात कर रहा हूं।
अगर आपने उसके कंट्रोल एस या कंट्रोल पी
को क्या किया? मॉडिफाई कर दिया। उसके साथ
छेड़छाड़ की तो फ्यूचर में क्या होगा? जब
भी आपका जो नॉर्मल यूजर है उस डॉक्यूमेंट
को सेव या प्रिंट करेगा। तो क्या होगा? जो
अटैकर्स का पेलोड है वह ऑटोमेटिकली
बैकग्राउंड में ट्रिगर हो जाएगा। और इससे
फायदा क्या होगा कि जो यूजर है उसको इस
बात पर बिल्कुल भी शक नहीं होगा कि यह
मशियस था। बिकॉज़ जो एक्शन था वो एक्शन
यूजर ने खुद परफॉर्म किया है। इसीलिए
पर्सिस्टेंस मैकेनिज्म पर्पस से भी हम
क्या करते हैं? इसका यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
पहला रीज़न। दूसरा रीज़न क्या है? इवेज एंड
डिफेंस बाईपासिंग। देयर आर मेनी
सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस दैट आर क्लोजली मॉनिटर
स्टैंडर्ड मैक ट्रिगर नेम्स सच एज ऑटो ओपन
हाउएवर बाय इंटरसेप्टिंग एंड ओवराइडिंग
एकिस्टिंग वर्ड कमांड्स अटैकर स्कटिक
सिक्योरिटी मॉनिटरिंग टूल्स एंड
एग्जीक्यूट पेलोड्स थ्रू रूटीन यूजर
इंटरेक्शंस मतलब यह क्या है कि बहुत से
सिक्योरिटी टूल्स क्या करते हैं जो
स्टैंडर्ड मैनेम्स होते हैं जो ज्यादातर
अब्यूज किए जाते हैं उनको क्या करते हैं
क्लोजली मॉनिटर करते हैं। लेकिन जब अटैकर
क्या करता है जो एग्ज़िस्टिंग
जो कॉमन वर्ड्स होते हैं जो हमेशा डेली
बेसिस पे यूज़ होते हैं जो कमांड्स होती है
अगर उनको इंटरसेप्ट या ओवराइड करने में
सक्सेस हो जाता है तो क्या कर सकता है जो
सिक्योरिटी मॉनिटरिंग टूल्स है उनको
बायपास कर सकता है और यूजर इंटरेक्शन के
जरिए उनको क्या करवा सकता है एग्जीक्यूट
करवा सकता है चुपचाप
तो यह है आपका वर्ड कमांड का खेल तो वर्ड
कमांड समझ में आया आपको कि वर्ड कमांड का
रोल क्या है? इसको भी वैसे भी आपका किसी
काम का नहीं है। एज ए बिगिनर्स आपको इसको
नहीं करना है। तो बेसिकली आपके पास आपको
ना तो इसको यूज़ करना है। ऑप्शन नंबर वन ना
ऑप्शन नंबर टू को यूज़ करना है ना ही ऑप्शन
नंबर थ्री को यूज़ करना है। ड्यूरिंग
क्रिएशन योर मिलसियस मैक डॉक्यूमेंट।
अब आते हैं हम
स्कोप नंबर फोर।
यह आपको यूज करना है। यही आपको यूज करना
है। आप बोलोगे सर कि आपने पूरा एक घंटा ले
लिया हमें ये चीज समझाने के लिए। पूरा 45
मिनट ले लिया आपने। और आप लास्ट में आप
बोल रहे हो कि हमें सिर्फ यही यूज़ करना
है। बाकी ये जो तीन है इनको यूज़ नहीं करना
है। तो सर आप स्टार्टिंग में ही क्यों
नहीं बता दिया कि यह तीन यूज़ नहीं करने
हैं भाई। चौथा यूज़ करना है। हम यूज़ ही
नहीं करते। बात ऐसी है मैं बता सकता था।
लेकिन जो सवाल है ना मन में कि क्यों यूज
नहीं करना है और अगर गलती से मैंने इनको
यूज कर लिया तो क्या होगा वो आपको पता
होना चाहिए क्योंकि कल को अगर गलती से यह
चीज हो भी गई तो आपको पता होगा कि गलती
कहां पर है
अंडरस्टुड? इसीलिए
अभी आपको ध्यान में रखना है जब भी आपको
क्या करना है मैक कोड डिजाइन करना है
मशियस मैक कोड डिजाइन करना है तो हमेशा
आपको यही ऑप्शन यूज़ करना है यह ऑप्शन क्या
करता है यह आपके मैक कोड को स्पेसिफिकली
आपकी जो करंट वर्ड फाइल है उसी के अंदर
एंबेड करता है और सबसे बड़ी बात ठीक है जब
आप इस डॉक्यूमेंट को किसी भी सिस्टम या
किसी भी वर्चुअल मशीन या किसी के भी कलीग,
फ्रेंड, किसी के साथ भी शेयर करोगे तो
आपका जो मैक कोड है वह हमेशा इस फाइल में
रहेगा। वह आपके सिस्टम पर नहीं छूट जाएगा
या ऐसा नहीं कि एम्प्टी फाइल चली जाएगी।
मतलब अगर इस ऑप्शन के साथ यहां पर
डॉक्यूमेंट वन इसलिए आ रहा है क्योंकि
हमने इस फाइल का नाम नहीं दिया। अगर इस
फाइल का नाम दोगे तो यहां पर फाइल नेम
आएगा। तो आपको हमेशा यही ऑप्शन सेलेक्ट
करना है जिससे बेनिफिट ये क्या है कि आप
जिसको भी भेजोगे इस डॉक्यूमेंट को इस कोड
के साथ ये मैक कोड इस डॉक्यूमेंट के साथ
ट्रैवल करेगा। सीधी सी बात है कि इस
डॉक्यूमेंट के साथ यह माइक्रो कोड ट्रैवल
करने वाला है।
तो इसलिए रिमेंबर आपको हमेशा एक और गोल्डन
यूज़ रूल याद रखना है कि व्हनेवर यू आर
क्रिएटिंग ए वीबीए पेलोड और एनी
डॉक्यूमेंट स्पेसिफिक मैकोड। ऑलवेज चेंज द
डिफ़ॉल्ट स्कोप टू सेलेक्ट द स्पेसिफिक
डॉक्यूमेंट। इसीलिए आपको हमेशा एक चीज याद
रखनी है कि जब भी आपको कोई भी वीबीए पे
लोड या डॉक्यूमेंट स्पेसिफिक मैक कोड
क्रिएट करना है चाहे वो मिलीसियस हो चाहे
वो मिलसियस ना हो तो आपको हमेशा यही ऑप्शन
सेलेक्ट करना है। इसके अलावा और कोई ऑप्शन
सेलेक्ट नहीं करना है। क्योंकि अगर इसके
अलावा आपने अगर ग्लोबल टेंपलेट ऑप्शन को
सेलेक्ट कर लिया तो होगा क्या कि जो आपका
माइक्रो कोड है वह आपके सिस्टम पे रह
जाएगा और आपकी जो डॉक्यूमेंट फाइल है वो
एंप्टी चली जाएगी टारगेट के पास और जिसका
कोई भी फायदा नहीं है। आपने इतनी मेहनत
की, रिसर्च की और आउटपुट क्या मिला? जीरो।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
चारों ऑप्शन समझ में आ गए?
सबको चारों ऑप्शन समझ में आ गए?
बताओ।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सबको चारों
ऑप्शन समझ में आए?
जल्दी से बताओ चैट में।
चलो अच्छी बात है। तो आज का सेशन इतना ही
करेंगे। आज मैंने आपको क्या चीज बताई?
कोई बताना चाहेगा आज मैंने आपको क्या
बताया?
मैंने आपको यह बताया है कि जब भी आप वीबीए
मै कोड डेवलप करना चाहते हो तो सबसे पहले
आपको दो स्टेप परफॉर्म करने हैं। एक तो
रिबन में आपको डेवलपर ऑप्शन सेलेक्ट करना
है। दूसरा एक और ऑप्शन मैंने आपको सेलेक्ट
करना बताया था। दूसरी चीज मैंने आपको क्या
बताई थी कि कोड लिखने से पहले एक स्कोप
है। स्कोप में चार ऑप्शंस होते हैं। ठीक
है? आपको स्कोप में चार ऑप्शंस मिलते हैं।
तो चारों में से कौन सा ऑप्शन आपको
सेलेक्ट करना है और कौन से ऑप्शन आपको
सेलेक्ट नहीं करने हैं और क्यों नहीं करने
हैं? चारों ऑप्शंस मैंने आपको अच्छे से
डिटेल में आपको एक्सप्लेन कर दिए हैं। तो
इसलिए कह सकते हो कि आज मैंने आपको क्या
बताया कि मैक्रोज और उसका सेटअप बताया
बेसिकली। उसके बाद नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम
क्या करेंगे? प्रैक्टिकल परफॉर्म करेंगे।
मैक्रोज कैसे परफॉर्म किया जाता है। ठीक
है? नेक्स्ट क्लास में बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग
से ही स्टार्ट किया मैंने। सारी चीजें मैं
आपको बताऊंगा कि वेरिएबल्स क्या होते हैं?
फंक्शनंस कैसे लिखे जाते हैं? सारी चीजें
मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं। ओके?
ठीक है? सारी चीजें मैं आपको बताने वाला
हूं।
मेरे पास Google ड्राइव में ड्राइव में
ज्यादा स्पेस नहीं है यार इसलिए प्रॉब्लम
है।
चलो मैं देखता हूं क्या कर सकता हूं
क्योंकि आप स्टूडेंट्स ज्यादा हो तो बाद
में उसमें प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट होगी। देखता
हूं आई विल ट्राई। तो आज का सेशन क्लियर
होगा आप लोगों को। सेशन से रिलेटेड किसी
का कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ सकते हो।
प्लीज बताइए सेशन से रिलेटेड किसी का कोई
डाउट है?
किसी को कोई भी डाउट है रिलेटेड टू द सेशन
या कुछ ऐसा लग रहा है कि सर हम क्या-क्या
पढ़ने वाले हैं। सच में मजा आने वाला है।
मैं आपको बहुत बहुत अच्छी-अच्छी चीजें
बताने वाला हूं। ऐसा प्रैक्टिकल सेशन नहीं
होगा। यह चीज मैं आपको बता रहा हूं। हर
चीज मैं बताने वाला हूं आपको।
नहीं, linx में मै रन क्यों होगा?
एक चीज समझने की कोशिश करो कि यू आर
लर्निंग Windows Windows प्लेटफार्म पे आप
क्या सीख रहे हो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
क्लाइंट अटैक में भी आप क्या करने की
कोशिश कर रहे हो कि आपको कैसे ना कैसे
करके फाइल ड्रॉप करनी है टारगेट सिस्टम के
ऊपर क्योंकि लinक्स का टॉपिक अलग था
लinक्स पे हम बाद में बात करेंगे अभी बात
चल रही है Windows की
अब आप ही बता बताइए कि Linux में
Microsoft Office नहीं यूज़ होता। ठीक है?
तो इसलिए VBA किसकी लैंग्वेज है? वीबीए
आपकी विजुअल बेसिक्स फॉर Microsoft Office
इसलिए Microsoft Office में काम करेगा।
तो आई होप सबको सेशन में सब कुछ क्लियर हो
गया होगा, समझ में आ गया होगा। तो कल से
हम क्या करने वाले हैं? नेक्स्ट क्लास से
और हां एक और चीज बता देता हूं आपको कि
अभी मैं कुछ क्लासेस खासकर यह जब तक वीवीए
मै कंप्लीट नहीं हो जाता ठीक है मैं इसको
कंटिन्यू ही कराएंगे हर सेकंड थर्ड डे पर
लगभग मैं इसको कंटिन्यू करने की कोशिश
करूंगा ओके ना कि रेदर देन कि नेक्स्ट
सैटरडे और संडे इस वीकेंड में वीक वीक डेज
में भी आपकी क्या वीकेंड्स के अंदर भी
आपके क्या रहेंगी क्लासेस रहेंगी नेक्स्ट
टॉपिक आपका इसी का ही रहेगा कि हम स्टार्ट
करेंगे बिल्कुल जीरो से। नेक्स्ट टॉपिक
यही है। प्रैक्टिकल सेशन हमने स्टार्ट
थोड़ी ना किया मैंने अभी। मैंने आपको
बताया है। सेटअप ही समझो अभी। ओके? सेटअप
ही समझो। उसके बाद हम बात करेंगे। जैसे
प्रोसीजर्स होते हैं, सब प्रोसीजर्स हो गए
आपके फंक्शनंस हो गए, वेरिएबल्स हो गए,
डेटा टाइप्स हो गए इसमें। जैसे कि फिर
आपके उसके बाद मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकली
दिखाऊंगा कि कैसे आप इसको यूज कर सकते हो
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में भी।
आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में भी प्रैक्टिकली
कैसे यूज कर सकते हो? कुछ तीन या चार
सिनेरियोस मैंने आप लोगों के लिए रेडी किए
हैं। जिसको मैं क्या करने वाला हूं?
प्रैक्टिकली इसी में परफॉर्म करके दिखाने
वाला हूं यहां पर लाइव क्लास में।
ओके
भाई मैक इज ए डिफरेंट थिंग। Python इज अ
डिफरेंट लैंग्वेज। Python को आप Microsoft
ऑफिस में नहीं चला सकते।
ओके
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। एंड एक और
चीज बता देता हूं। कल सेशन नहीं होगा
क्योंकि कल शॉप की क्लास आ रही है इसलिए
मेरा सेशन नहीं है। तो मेरा सेशन मंडे को
होगा। तो बी रेडी फॉर मंडे। मंडे को हम
फिर से यहीं से कंटिन्यू करने वाले हैं।
ओके? तो चलिए फिर बाय-ब एवरीवन एंड गुड
नाइट एवरीवन।